increasing numbers of Europeans of
crossing borders like this one into
Syria to fight alongside the opposition
Free Syrian Army many are idealists but
some of these foreign fighters return
radicalized by their experience and
compose a danger to the nations of the
EU it's a phenomenon that interior
ministers will discuss this week in
luxembourg based on a document prepared
by the EU counterterrorism coordinator
you need to work on on how to prevent
people from leaving europe to go to
syria and what you do when they get back
you need to mobilize the classic of
response more information sharing among
the intelligence services and the law
enforcement agencies get a better sense
of of special travels and that requires
that you collect more travel data and
finally we need to engage more with the
country of transit the country from from
where a lot of foreign fighters are
coming from so get a bit more
international cooperation on that front
the problem of people crossing Europe's
borders to fight and train in Syria but
also places like Somalia or Yemen has
taken on greater prominence since the
killing of a British soldier in London
and the stabbing of a French soldier
last month British and French ministers
will update their colleagues on those
investigations more broadly the
ministers will discuss ways to improve
their analysis of the problem prevent
people from wanting to leave on such
missions pursue those who do by using
travel data and imposing legal or
administrative sanctions and look to
boosting cooperation with international
partners in separate discussions the
council will look at ways to improve the
protection of refugees fleeing Syria to
places like Jordan Lebanon and Turkey
more than four million people have been
forced from their homes during the
two-year long conflict